[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette campagne salle après salle on
entre avec françois-xavier bien
évidemment de l'émotion pour nous mais
il ya une profonde gratitude
une gratitude pour vous
qui nous avait accompagnés pendant la
totalité de cette campagne
une gratitude pour vous qui répondait
présent une gratitude pour vous qui avez
redonné à la droite et au centre son
enthousiasme et quand on rentre dans
cette salle et consorts vous êtes là pas
pour nous et pour les convictions pour
partage pour ce que nous menons ensemble
avec françois-xavier avec toute la liste
c'est plus beau des encouragements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début de cette campagne je
l'entend partout en france partout où
nous allons
je l'entends monter cette défiance cette
défiance qui a produit le break site
elle existe aussi en france cette
défiance qui fait que tant
d'agriculteurs temps d'entrepreneurs
temps de salariés tant d'ouvriers ont le
sentiment que l'europe nous fragilise au
lieu de nous renforcer
bien sûr nous croyons à l'europe est
notre famille politique est engagée
comme jamais dans le travail européen
parce que nous croyons que l'europe est
plus nécessaire que jamais mais nous
croyons aussi que pour que l'europe
puisse nous renforcer dans la
mondialisation il faut la réorienter en
profondeur il faut refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la paix voilà le
projet qui est devant et voilà pourquoi
il est nécessaire de rentrer dans le
fond dans les sujets concrets qui
préoccupent les français
[Musique]
nous l'europe que nous voulons c'est
l'europe des projets quand on nous
demande quelle europe nous voulons nous
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
qui parce qu'elle sait qu'il est laid
est capable d'imposer sa puissance dans
le monde nos de l'europe que nous
voulons c'est une robe qui n'a pas
oublié son identité
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
civilisation c'est cette europe là que
nous portons dans ce jour celle en fait
c'est un but que tu veux chers jeunes
qui est ici ce soir
chers amis nous avons besoin de vous
pour reconstruire une famille parce que
nous croyons pour reconstruire cette
famille politique qui a le sens de la
transmission pour reconstruire cette
famille politique qui croit à la force
de la france mais qui croit que la force
de la france suppose qu'elle se libère
des freins qu'elle s'impose à elle même
pour reconstruire cette famille
politique qui mettra fin à la menace
terroriste pour reconstruire cette
famille politique qui offrira demain un
nouvel espoir à la france nous avons
besoin de vous chers amis nous sommes
les enfants de cette histoire magnifique
nous sommes les enfants de l'idéalisme
de platon de la juste mesure d'aristote
des hommes des enfants de cicéron et de
marc aurèle cet empereur qui savaient
plus chaque matin c'est pour faire peur
aux hommes qu'on se réveille
nous sommes les enfants des paysans qui
ont défriché l'europe nous sommes des
enfants de chevalier qui ont inventé le
code de l'honneur nous sommes les
enfants de cet héritage des lumières qui
a développé la raison critique
nous sommes les enfants de ce2 14 et des
résistants de 40 qui ont fait notre
liberté d'aujourd'hui au prix de leur
vie
nous devons nous montrer à la hauteur de
cette histoire et nous serons à la
hauteur de cette histoire et c'est
exactement ce qui se joue dans les dix
jours qui viennent je voudrais dans les
années qui viendront avec tous mes
colistiers au parlement européen pouvoir
être votre voix mais pendant les dix
jours qui viennent il faut que vous
soyez notre foi car vous seul pouvez
faire cette victoire dont nous avons
tellement besoin
vous seul vous n'êtes pas venus écouter
vous êtes venus agir
vous n'êtes pas venus écouter vous êtes
venu vous engager et cette victoire sera
la vôtre pour refonder l'europe et pour
rétablir la france merci de tout coeur
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]